in the final paragraph of the origin of
species darwin famously writes
there is grandeur in this view of life
with its several powers having been
originally breathed into a few forms or
into one
and that from so simple a beginning
endless forms most beautiful and most
wonderful have been and are being
evolved
here darwin is saying that species not
only evolved
they are evolving
the science of evolution is not just a
historical science allowing us to
reconstruct the past and present
evolution is also an ongoing process
a way to understand how all species will
continue to change
in other words
evolution gives us a way to make
predictions about the future
including our own future
so what's going to happen to us
let's be optimistic let's assume we
don't go extinct
after all homo erectus lasted a million
years or more
perhaps human civilization will overcome
current and future threats and continue
much longer
if so then the history of life on earth
suggests just two broad possibilities
either we continue changing and
eventually evolve into new species
or we evolve in ways that leave us more
or less the way we are today
the evolution from non-humans to humans
was rapid and dramatic
since we split with the common ancestor
we shared with chimpanzees between five
and seven million years ago our
ancestors went from walking on four legs
to walking upright
we lost most of our body hair and gained
lots of sweat glands
and most significantly we developed
large brains capable of complex thought
and sophisticated language
will this rapid rate of change continue
if we are continuing to evolve will our
descendants be as obviously different 5
million years in the future as we are
today from our ancestors 5 million years
in the past
maybe not
the trend toward larger and larger
brains stopped about 10 000 years ago
and modern brains are actually smaller
than those of neanderthals
darwin said that evolution is inevitable
but he never claimed that the changes
had to be obvious
we know of examples of other organisms
that survive for millions of years
without much visible change to their
body structure
fish known as coelacanths are sometimes
called living fossils because modern
coelacanths look so similar to 150 to
350 million year old coelacanth fossils
other animals that have looked about the
same for many millions of years include
horseshoe crabs crocodiles and sharks
how could evolution be happening without
obvious physical changes
for one thing the red queen hypothesis
running as fast as you can just to stay
in place
suggests that all species constantly
evolve just to maintain their defenses
in the arms race against infectious
diseases and other parasites
species can even evolve in one direction
for a while but then reverse direction
like galapagos finches whose beak sizes
change as food availability fluctuates
the net result of many fluctuations
could be ending up being pretty much the
same many generations in the future
moreover in many regions of the world
including the united states canada and
much of western europe
infectious diseases are no longer the
primary causes of death
as a result those infectious diseases
may no longer be causing natural
selection to favor disease resistance
unlike in the past
the observation that diseases aren't
causing natural selection in some modern
human populations has prompted a
minority of well-known biologists to go
so far as to claim that human evolution
is basically over
they include biologists ernst mayer and
stephen j gould geneticist steve jones
anthropologist ian tattersall as well as
nature commentator sir david
attenborough
their argument is that our evolution
stops with the advance of modern
civilization
after all more and more of us live in
carefully constructed environments that
separate us from the natural environment
we grow our foods at industrial scales
and shop at supermarkets where local
availability and seasonal cycles have
become almost meaningless
we treat genetic and infectious diseases
with medicine
and can have surgery to repair birth
defects or injuries
when darwin published his theory
only about 50 percent of all british
children survived to adulthood
even with the best available care only
seven of darwin's 10 children survive to
adulthood
by contrast in the uk today fully 99
survive
but has our culture really replaced
natural selection as the driving force
affecting humans today
as a biologist who has spent much of my
life studying ants i see a lot of
parallels between insect and human
societies
for many biologists like me
culture is simply another part of the
natural environment much as it is for
other highly social species like ants
leafcutter ants build nests that are
much like human cities where millions of
individuals live in high densities
inside carefully built structures that
provide protection from the outside
world
most of their babies or larvae survive
to adulthood
like us leafcutter ants grow their food
a type of fungus at industrial scales
they also protect themselves from
disease by promoting the growth of
bacteria that produce antibiotics
they have overlapping generations for
continuity and a division of labor that
makes possible a complex way of life
ants evolved advanced social
organization with complex artificial
environments some 100 million years ago
but that didn't stop ant evolution
in fact it's been only after the
creation of complex artificial
environments that ants went on to evolve
such diverse body shapes and sizes diets
and nesting habits resulting in more
than 15 000 species of ants alive today
and while we have not evolved into many
different species social insects have a
100 million year head start on us
thinking of culture as part of the
environment makes it easier to recognize
that natural selection operates on
transmissible culture in humans just as
it does in any other species
moreover the culture we transmit is a
also a highly changeable feature of our
environment
think about how quickly fashions change
you could say that for fashion and other
aspects of culture mutations are high
heritability is low and there's a great
deal of horizontal transfer between
individuals
what all this suggests is that fashions
can evolve but that it may not evolve in
a particular direction for long because
it can change at a pace that is far
faster than a human generation
one difference between human societies
and insect societies is that a single
largely intermixing species of humans
already occupies all land masses on
earth
despite their 100 million year head
start on us
no single group of ants or other social
insects ever expanded to occupy the
entire globe on their own
it was only thanks to humans that super
colonies like those of the argentine
ants have been created when humans
accidentally transported them across
continents
moreover having a global range is only
part of the human story
other species migrate over long
distances but they aren't global in the
same way that humans are
even humpback whales which occupy most
of the world's oceans have distinct
populations in different regions
unlike humans whales from one population
rarely interact with whales from other
populations
biologists use the term pan-miktik to
refer to a large population that freely
interbreeds like the globe skimmer a
migratory dragonfly species found on
every continent except antarctica
but perhaps the best comparison for our
modern interbreeding human population is
bacteria
like modern humans bacteria move around
the planet exchanging genes
and they do it even more than we do
and although bacteria reproduce
asexually by budding bacteria do
exchange genes by swapping pieces of dna
compared to bacteria humans are not yet
a pan-mictic species we are still more
likely to reproduce with people who live
near us
but our global transportation networks
and high rates of population movements
have been pushing us in more of the
direction of becoming s panmectic as
bacteria
what does the movement of people and our
genes around the world mean for our
evolution
one thing global transportation does is
allow us to rapidly move infectious
diseases like viruses
the 2009 global outbreak of swine flu
during just a few weeks is only one
example
as long as we have fast global
transportation new infectious diseases
will be a threat to human health
one major source for new diseases are
microorganisms that infect animals as
well as humans like influenza zika
rabies and loss of fever we can't as
effectively target and eliminate such
diseases in animals particularly wild
animals
how has our rapid economic development
influence natural selection in recent
and modern human populations
an obvious result of better access to
clean water abundant food and modern
health care is declining death rates due
especially to lower infant and child
mortality rates
a less intuitive consequence of economic
development is that lower death rates
tend to be followed by lower birth rates
and even greater parental investment per
child
the decline in both death rates and
birth rates is known as the demographic
transition
and it has important consequences for
how humans are continuing to evolve
for example much of the united states
experienced a demographic transition
beginning in the 1800s
population records from utah showed that
during the 1800s most individuals
increasingly survived into old age
yet even as average birth rates declined
there was still variation in family
sizes
even though there was less opportunity
for natural selection to act on traits
related to survival
selection could still affect traits
related to fertility how long people
lived was becoming more similar most
lived into old age but people still
differed in how many children they had
in fact the differences in family size
meant that the opportunity for selection
to affect fertility
increased throughout the 1800s even
after the demographic transition there's
been an evolutionary change in the
timing of reproduction
but it's not toward later reproduction
it's tort earlier
the entire history of a population of
french canadians living on an island in
the st lawrence river was traced using
parish records
women who began having children earlier
in life tended to have more children
over their lifespan
and daughters of women who started their
families at a younger age
also tended to become mothers younger
natural selection led to a reduction in
the average age at first birth for women
during a period of more than 120 years
natural selection has been shown to
favor an earlier start to reproduction
in other populations too
the framingham heart study began in 1948
to track the health and well-being of
people in a suburb of boston
based on two generations of data women
who began having children at a younger
age had more children over their entire
lifespan
other factors that contributed to larger
family sizes in the framingham study
were experiencing menopause at a later
age and being slightly shorter heavier
and having lower cholesterol levels
if those trends continue then women 10
generations in the future would be
expected on average to be even shorter
and heavier have even lower cholesterol
levels and blood pressure and become
mothers at an even younger age and
experience menopause even later
population bottlenecks deep in our human
past gave us our current low levels of
human genetic diversity
but that is changing fast
our global population is approaching 8
billion with about 130 million babies
born worldwide each year as we saw
earlier in the course each baby has on
average about 60 new mutations in its
genes
these mutations contribute to the
diversity of the human gene pool and
represent the raw material for natural
selection to shape our evolutionary
future
in addition there's a trend toward older
fathers in many regions including the
united states that will increase human
genetic diversity more and more rapidly
that's because fathers of any age
contribute more mutations to their
children than mothers and older fathers
contribute more mutations to their kids
than younger fathers
in short the total supply of human
mutations the raw material for human
evolution are in the process of
exploding in number
meanwhile gene flow is increasing with
the rapid movement of people around the
globe
populations today that were once widely
separated now have many more
opportunities to exchange genes through
sex and reproduction
gene flow makes populations more similar
to one another so one consequence of the
high rates of gene flow in modern human
populations
is that some of the differences that
once existed between human populations
may start to disappear
for example
people of the future may increasingly
have similar skin hair and eye colors
but more importantly gene flow can
spread helpful mutations much faster to
other populations than would have
previously been possible
this could mean for example that a
mutation that provides natural
protection against a particular
infectious disease could spread in just
a few generations to the regions where
that disease is most common
of course organisms that cause disease
will continue to evolve too global
travel patterns are creating more
opportunities for infectious diseases to
quickly shift hosts
based on our understanding of virulence
we should expect that some infectious
diseases will evolve to make us sicker
increased virulence won't necessarily
decrease their odds of finding a new
host
just think about how easy it is to catch
a bug from someone sitting near you on
an airplane
if our diseases get worse
will we just keep on evolving new
defenses leading to an intensified
evolutionary arms race
perhaps but keep in mind that
microorganisms can evolve a lot faster
than we can
that's a sobering thought we may be
helping our diseases evolve against us
but remember that we also have
microorganisms on our side
our microbiome consists of millions of
bacteria and other microbes some of
which evolved along with us and can help
us to stay healthy
those microbes will keep on evolving too
and it's in our best interest to ensure
that the helpful ones continue to have a
home in and on our bodies
maintaining beneficial microorganisms
that can promote health is a good reason
to use antibiotics responsibly
but it would be even better to develop
more ways to eliminate only those
microorganisms that cause disease
without also harming the beneficial
members of our microbiome
so many human populations have undergone
a demographic transition leading to more
opportunities for selection to operate
on traits related to reproduction
what does this help us say about the
future of human sexual selection
traits related to reproduction are
becoming more relevant to our evolution
than traits related to survival
in other words to consider our future
evolution we need to think a lot more
about sex and reproduction
darwin already suggested that mate
choice can be a powerful mechanism of
evolution leading to traits like the
elaborate tales of peacocks that can't
be otherwise easily explained
humans are sexually dimorphic on average
men tend to be taller more muscular and
have more facial hair than women
that suggests that sexual selection has
operated on our species in the past
sexual selection is still operating
today but now sexual selection can be
separated from reproduction
both by the use of birth control to
prevent pregnancy and by technologies
that promote pregnancy without sex and
births that don't rely on the birth
canal
let's consider technologies that promote
pregnancy
thanks to techniques like in vitro
fertilization couples experiencing
infertility today have a better chance
of conceiving children
in the past infertility that ran in
families would be strongly affected by
natural selection since people with
infertility contribute fewer genes to
the next generation
in other words infertile families would
become less and less common
but assisted reproductive technologies
counteract natural and sexual selection
and could make infertility more common
in the 21st century over one percent of
u.s births involve in vitro
fertilization in the uk it's over two
percent and in scandinavian countries
it's even higher
if these rates continue to climb it
could make future generations more
dependent on assisted reproductive
technologies and might lead eventually
to complete dependence on such
technologies for reproduction
another reproductive technology that may
already be affecting our evolution is
cesarean sections in childbirth
although c-sections have been performed
since ancient times the fact that they
are now much safer has made some of them
routine in some regions
in the united states nearly one-third of
all births are by c-section and in
brazil it's one-half
throughout human history the size of our
heads has co-evolved with the size of
the birth canal
but as c-sections become more common the
birth canal is no longer as much of a
constraint on head size
if at some point all births are
performed by c-section that would allow
us to evolve larger heads and brains in
the future
having heads too big to fit through the
birth canal would also make us
completely dependent on c-sections
reinforcing the trend
how far might our dependence on
technology go
some futurists believe that humans will
eventually merge with our technologies
leading to the creation of trans humans
in fact futurists can point to some ways
this process has already begun
we can already attach artificial limbs
to help us move implant artificial
hearts to help pump our blood and insert
cochlear implants to help us hear
many of us are addicted to our
smartphones and in the future we may be
able to implant computers to enhance our
brains or allow us to communicate
telepathically
if we ever get to the point where we
become so intimately dependent on
technology for survival
would that fundamentally alter our
evolution
probably not and here's why
one of the major insights from the
modern synthesis was that recognition
that only heritable traits can
evolve with the partial and short-term
exceptions of epigenetics and culture
heritability requires being encoded in
our genes
as long as our technology has to be
freshly implanted embedded or inserted
into our bodies with each new generation
it can't evolve in the same way as
living species
unless we find a way to encode our
technology into our dna
technology will merely affect our
evolution by the impacts it has on
survival and reproduction
we might evolve in response to our
technologies like we do in response to
other aspects of our cultural
environment like diet or reproductive
technologies
we may even be able to train more and
more of our digital technology with
evolutionary algorithms similar to how
we already write digital life
simulations or computer viruses that
mutate
but the technology itself won't be a
part of our biological evolution
one way that technology could take us in
a new evolutionary direction is if we
begin to edit the genomes of the human
germline as we've already seen the
ability to edit the human genome through
technology like crispr could make it
possible to direct our own future
evolution
but to get to that point safely we'll
need to learn a lot more
evolution is all about incremental
trade-offs not about perfect blueprints
so any new changes we try are likely to
include new trade-offs
another possible game changer for our
future evolution could be the
establishment of permanent colonies
beyond earth
such colonies could be a way to make
sure our species survives long into the
future even if some disaster occurs on
earth
but there's an irony to colonizing space
to preserve our species
because leaving earth might trigger
rapid evolutionary changes
that's because people living in colonies
on mars or elsewhere in the galaxy would
be subject to even stronger forces of
natural selection than on earth due to
the extreme differences in physical
conditions
in the case of mars its gravity is about
38 percent of earth's gravity
humans living there would be at greater
risk for bone loss because bone becomes
more brittle when gravity is weaker
humans living on mars might evolve
thicker bones at birth to reduce the
risk of life-threatening fractures later
in life like during childbirth
another reason why selection would be
stronger on mars is radiation
the thin atmosphere and lack of a
protective magnetosphere means that more
radiation hits the surface of mars than
on earth
humans living on the surface of mars
would be exposed to almost 100 times the
amount of radiation received each year
by the average person on earth
and nearly five times the annual limit
permitted for u.s radiation workers
how might people on mars protect
themselves
physical barriers will help but any time
spent on the surface for example to tend
crops would mean significant radiation
exposure
skin pigmentation might evolve to
provide some amount of radiation
protection
on earth the pigment eumelanin in our
skin provides some protections against
ultraviolet radiation
other organisms on earth use additional
pigments like carotenoids
most animals get carotenoids for their
diet
carotenoids are what make carrots orange
but we've seen one case in which aphids
acquire genes to make carotenoids
themselves
acquiring the carotenoid genes from
fungi caused these normally green
insects to become orange
if humans on mars acquired genes for
making carotenoids it might lead to
bright orange martians
the high levels of radiation on mars and
elsewhere in space could also contribute
to rapid human evolution because
radiation damages dna leading to
mutations
while these mutations would lead to a
higher rate of birth defects in cancer
they would also introduce more variety
into the gene pool providing more raw
material for natural selection
together both stronger natural selection
and a higher rate of mutation would make
evolution much faster for people living
on mars than it is on earth
also humans living beyond earth might
choose to accelerate such changes even
more
why wait around for helpful mutations if
we can use crispr to edit our genes
directly
artificial or directed selection for
humans who are better adapted to the
conditions on mars would improve the
quality of life in extraterrestrial
colonies
as people become adapted to conditions
in colonies on mars and elsewhere
eventually these changes could cause
humans living on different planets to
diverge in much the same way as species
living on different islands here on
earth
the more they remain isolated the more
the characteristics of humans might
diverge in just a few dozen generations
even so just occasional contact like in
the past between neanderthals denisovans
and homo sapiens
might include sex between groups and
babies that survive to adulthood
divergent human species could happen
even faster without a functional immune
system
as far as we know there aren't any
microorganisms outside of earth so the
immune systems of extraterrestrial
humans may atrophy
without a functional immune system
contact with people from microbe-rich
environments like earth would be very
risky because the immune compromised
martians could be killed by any type of
infection
contact between people on earth and mars
especially sexual contact might become
too risky
and without sexual contact between the
two populations people on mars would
begin to diverge from people on earth
through the usual processes of mutation
genetic drift and natural and sexual
selection
in a few hundred generations perhaps as
little as six thousand years a new type
of human might emerge
if that happens i'd like to think that
darwin wouldn't be too surprised
he knew that birds and tortoises living
on different islands in the galapagos
can evolve into distinct species
aren't species living on different
planets in our solar system much the
same
it seems fitting that darwin's theory of
evolution not only tells us about our
past but may help us navigate the future
of life
after all since the modern synthesis in
the middle of the 20th century
evolution has become the central
framework that unites all other
subfields of biology
you might say that what darwin didn't
know is how much his ideas would become
a framework for ongoing curiosity about
all of life
is the underlying reason why research on
fruit flies or mice can have any direct
relevance to humans
our common evolutionary history means
that their genetics to an astonishing
degree is our genetics
evolution guides our efforts to rescue
endangered species
we know that bringing together separated
populations can limit bottleneck effects
of genetic drift and may help them to
avoid an extinction vortex
evolution is the reason we know that
bacteria evolve rapidly and why we're
learning to be more careful when
prescribing and using antibiotics
evolution is why we are taking far more
interest in the human microbiome
we've learned that some of our microbial
entourage have been our long-term
evolutionary partners and that they can
help to keep us healthy in the
ever-changing fight against harmful
microbes
in short as theodosius debzanski one of
the most influential evolutionary
biologists since darwin put it
succinctly in a 1973 essay
nothing in biology makes sense except in
the light of evolution
evolution tells us who we are
where we come from
and where we might be headed
when charles darwin's voyage on the
beagle was almost over
shortly after setting foot in south
america for the last time
he wrote his sister a letter that
revealed just how much he had changed
during his five-year journey
his early enthusiasm for travel was gone
as he declared
i loathe i abhor the sea and all ships
which sail on it
in fact he never sailed again
but in that same letter we also see that
something else had replaced his youthful
wanderlust
he wrote
a man who dares to waste one hour of
time has not discovered the value of
life
it may be that charles darwin's most
fundamental discovery was his methodical
unifying curiosity about the value of
life
all of life
darwin suspected that all of life is
related on a tree of life all the way
down to the genomes we are learning how
to edit
charles darwin's very last book
just a year before he died was all about
earthworms
what they could do
what they could sense and even how
intelligent they might be
he wondered for example if earthworms
could hear anything
so he had his grandson blow a whistle
a son played low notes on a bassoon and
his wife played the piano very loudly
it's funny and inspiring how darwin
never stopped trying to learn what he
did not know
and we can do the same
darwin's fundamental idea how all of
life is connected and evolves has an
intrinsic grandeur that can inform and
enrich us every day
[Music]
[Music]
you